what what do you think uh happens in
terms of
young people who could never afford to
buy homes
uh or maybe weren't as interested in
them this millennial generation
um at this point in time you have these
millennials who maybe weren't interested
in owning homes
but then maybe we're starting to think
about you know they're starting to trade
on robin hood maybe growing up a little
bit
and then they get hit with a sick
pandemic that kind of
after you know maybe not even having the
ability to participate in honor
[ __ ] because their parents uh you know
did all you know bought up all the
inventory so
what happens to this next generation do
you think do you think about that ever
we all the time we have a lot of
millennial clients
um so i i think
over half of our clients are between
sort of
25 and 35 really
yeah when you think about our registered
users and then another big chunk is 35
to 45.
so it tends to skew younger and 93
of our homes are sold to people who are
buying out of state
and about you know 75
are first-time real estate investors so
it's it's with what we're seeing is a
lot of millennials
getting on the property ownership
bandwagon where they don't live
and it's been a phenomenon of renting in
an expensive city and buying these less
expensive homes all over the country
to start to build a portfolio build some
passive income and some exposure
what i'm seeing now is
a lot of those people thinking about
moving to places they might have bought
a rental home and say oh my god
yeah i bought this rental home in
pittsburgh and it's it's
you know it's dope yes i i i could go
buy a home for 200
000 that is really nice and i could work
out of there i think a lot of people are
going back to be
near family or near places they they
might be familiar with
and they're discovering that they can
have an amazing life
just because the financial burden is so
much less
and they get more space and so it's
a whole different pace so i think you're
going to continue to see a migration of
younger people
going to these secondary cities
like the pittsburghs or the nashvilles
or
the cincinnati's of the world kansas
city
st louis where you can go and have a
great life
and and do your job and so um
but i do think that millennials like
real estate
and based on our research they trust a
real estate investment a lot more than
they trust the stock market
the trust in the stock market is
generally inversely
proportional to your age so um
it's it's fascinating um that makes
sense to me because if you look at the
stock market over multiple decades
yes you feel very comfortable with it
but if you're only
been an adult for half a decade or one
decade
it's kind of hard to understand i know i
didn't get a full appreciation
appreciation for it until after the
dot-com bust
and when i had my second decade as an
adult when i was in my 30s or 40s i was
like
oh stocks go up
but they also go down but they overall
go up
and they go up faster than other things
so you really want to
have a blended portfolio yeah i hate to
stereotype but
but um
you know as a generation one might say
that they have a little add
right yeah having a wanting this
immediate
uh result uh just everyone's used to
having stuff on demand so the idea that
yeah over the next 20 or 30 years you
can count with
you know pretty a great degree of
certainty
the stock market's going to be
significantly higher but it may be
really volatile and may
go down 20 percent um i
mean that that's that's not something
that sort of horizon i think is hard
for a lot of but people don't realize
about that add
thing my friend doug rushkoff the the
media theorist
he thought adhd was something our
generation gen x
had as a defense mechanism or adaptation
to mtv
and video games and screens just moving
faster and faster right so we kind of
got trained
to think on our feet move move around a
little bit more and that's obviously
continue with the smartphone generation
so therefore
that adaptation allows you to be less
tied to one thing
and you get more exposure to many things
and you get more reps
so we thought staying in a job i don't
know your your gen x like me i think
we thought you had to stay in a job a
minimum of four years if it was less
than four years it was like a blemish on
your resume
and now you see you know this generation
is like yeah i stayed there four months
because it wasn't right for me
uh i wasn't going to suffer for another
three and a half years [ __ ] that like
i'm out
uh and so that actually gives them
if they're screwing around with sports
betting and then doing robinhood or
betting on crypto
or betting on housing they're gonna get
so many reps that they're gonna become
good at it quicker because
most old people are just like i don't
know anything about housing i don't know
anything about crypto i don't know about
stock market i only know this
that's an interesting insight in
perspective more reps
um i think that's right i think a lot of
times people are looking at
a portfolio career today not a job
people are doing lots of side hustles
and
investing in different things um trying
different things and
moving around to a lot of jobs i think
you're right
um i do think it's not always
constructive when it comes to
the career side because i i think
sometimes the first six months to 12
months in a job
um it really you're just learning and
you're not
generally all that effective and and
then
that next kind of two three years you
could really crush it and i think a lot
of times people
will give up too quickly and move for a
title or move to another hot company
and they think they're progressing and
they may be progressing in title but
maybe not in
skills and actual uh
kind of a portfolio of work and i think
at some point that catches up with a lot
of people
and they find themselves at a level
where they're not actually not as
competent as they would have been had
they stayed
because it takes you time to build
relationships and trust
learn the business so that's one bit of
counsel i have for younger people i
i talk to is think about the the
negative of the of that hopping around
is you've got this kind of built-in
equity and i'm not talking about the
financial equity you're building but the
social equity that you're building
in your organization and then you start
to increasingly become more valuable
and learn and learn after that kind of
first year
i always tell people when they're coming
to work for me i expect four years
and do are you prepared to do that and
here's the value of that is you're going
to get
unbelievable opportunities and exposure
so we'll just keep pushing stuff on your
plate
and for me it's sort of like what you're
saying i think when your boss
and the management trust you you've now
achieved like the really important thing
which is
the next time something important comes
along they go who did the last two
important things and how did that turn
out
oh yeah that kid who's been with us 18
months let's give him this really big
important thing that would be
career changing for him yeah personal
story so um first time i applied to
business school i just applied to
stanford did not get in i had two years
of work experience
my boss said at the time he goes listen
you
work for me for another year i'll give
you two projects to run you've proven
yourself
and reapply based on that additional
experience
i got so much more experience in that
third year than i did in the first two i
actually got to lead a couple projects
and i got in
so i ended up going to stanford and i
had i
you know i could have gone to another
school with when i with two years of
work experience if i was in a hurry to
just go to business school but that but
that
is kind of my point i i learned so much
more in that third year because i'm
actually reasonably competent
and it built an up enough internal trust
to do that